i want to start with a sincere
congratulations on the movie i thought
you guys did all such a great job um i
can't imagine what it's like being a
part of a film like this
like what really surprised you about
making a film on this like scale and
scope
well i feel like
um just how much
around there's around the the process of
shooting
like so
we work with this woman she's called
polly bennett she's the movement coach
for everybody yeah she gets you to a
point where like you come in and you're
like what am i doing and she'll be like
i got you and like and she gets you up
to that point that by the time you get
uh
on set at least you have like the
choreography of like how you're gonna
survive
this gargantuan responsibility and feat
and
baz then is like he's gonna be like
making sure that you are like
doing is giving everything you need to
be giving he's gonna be extending you
but like so it's like a real duality
between those two roles but so much of
this work is offset so i had to do like
this movement coaching and then i had
like two different guitar coaches
because i had to learn to shred
um and
like there's just so much and then they
send you over to cm and then there's
like a big old building there that's
like all costume like just like racks
racks racks racks works forever so
you're saying that making a movie is not
just showing up on set and just smiling
i'm joking around i know but for real
like
it's it's so much like the the scale of
it like it's very hard to imagine but
and the research that's required it's so
hard to imagine and then i've got to
sing with dental prosthetics and you'll
notice my teeth are different
like
yeah and so then i have to re learn to
move my consonants but i've had a brace
when i grew up so i remember with a
plate in and it's like basically the
same so if you ever had a brace you can
sing with prosthetics in but like it's
yeah it was a lot like of just all the
stuff you don't know you've got to learn
how to shred and sing
but you've got to do that and you can't
look at your fingers
and you've got to see the mark on the
floor because you can't run through shot
and you've got to keep baz in your eye
so you can't do that and you've got to
interact with the other people in your
scene um and so like you're not thinking
about all of those other things that
you've got to do you're just thinking
about what you're doing yourself and
it's all so much more outward and
performing as an artist as a recording
artist it's all very it can be as inward
as you like
so it's like they're the kind of inverse
of each other did you find a new
appreciation for actors after making
this movie that maybe you didn't have
from before absolutely because i started
out in modeling and in fashion which is
completely different from acting with
acting you get to develop an empathy for
your character you get to learn and dive
in and research and kind of surrender to
that and you become one with that and
lose yourself in that so it's a lot of
what yola just said but when you're on
that stage you kind of
have an out-of-body experience when all
of those elements the cameras bars the
extras it becomes one you have no choice
but to just be
then there you are you know because the
set is so perfectly designed you walk in
and you feel like you are really in that
period and you are that and the way cm
is designing the outfits and when you
put it on you like oh word like i feel i
am a little wretched up in this loop
so um it really was a beautiful
experience that i developed newfound
love and appreciation for on that note i
need to stop but i was a sincere
congrats
you